president biden just announced a
sweeping vaccine mandate that will be
enforced by the occupational safety and
health administration or osha he also
issued an even stricter executive order
requiring all federal employees and
federal contractors to get vaccinated
is that legal
so let's first talk about the federal
employees and contractors president
biden signed a new executive order
mandating that all federal employees and
contractors get vaccinated against cobit
19 with no exceptions for those who
agree to regular testing for the virus
president biden's vaccine mandates are
actually a series of executive orders
and executive orders don't actually
control the citizens that's exclusively
up to laws of congress what an executive
order does is it orders the federal
agencies because the president is the
head executive and
effectively tells them to do something
so long as that executive order doesn't
conflict with the laws that congress
passes this isn't the first time that
president biden has made an executive
order related to kovid or is it the
first time that he's used the mechanism
of ordering osha to do something back in
july the president ordered healthcare
providers to provide training
ventilation and ppe to their healthcare
workers however under that executive
order every federal agency was
responsible for setting up their own
procedures and testing protocols that
led to a complicated situation where
different rules applied in different
agencies the agencies also expressed
frustration with implementing a routine
testing regime public-facing healthcare
agencies such as veteran affairs and
health and human services had already
mandated that their frontline health
workers be vaccinated with exceptions
only for those who require religious or
health-based accommodations at the va
employees have until october to be fully
vaccinated meanwhile after the fda gave
full approval to the pfizer vaccine the
defense department announced it would
require all service members to get
vaccinated and that's not surprising as
the federal government had generally
avoided mandating vaccines that had only
been authorized for temporary use but
biden's executive order gives the white
house safer federal workforce task force
seven days to issue new guidance on how
agencies should implement the new
vaccine mandate biden press secretary
jen saki said employees will have 75
days to get fully vaccinated or apply
for a religious or medical exemption
before they will be deemed out of
compliance with the order under the
prior executive order each agency would
decide whether to require employees to
provide proof of their vaccination
status or they could simply attest that
they had received it saki said that
under the new order agencies can
continue to make their own decision
about whether to use the honor system
the bind administration also said there
will be limited disability and religious
exceptions to the federal employee
vaccine requirement all other employees
and contractors will face termination if
they don't get vaccinated now this one
is pretty easy from a legal standpoint
presidents receive wide latitude in
dealing with federal contractors because
they're basically just acting as part of
an arm's length agreement and to the
extent that there are rules and there
aren't that many those are governed by
the procurement act that was passed in
the 1940s and under that act the
standard is pretty low the president
can't create a rule that's just meant to
meddle with the internal affairs of the
federal contractor the president just
needs to show that the action is somehow
necessary for a federal benefit and here
the benefit is pretty obvious if you
demand that your contractors get
vaccinated the members of the federal
government are less likely to be
infected though perhaps that's not the
case with absolutely every single
federal contractor maybe there are some
that don't interact with federal
employees and then the federal benefit
becomes more and more tenuous but for
the most part the president is going to
win these battles against federal
contractors if they dispute this mandate
here president biden's order will be
implemented by the general services
administration or gsa as well as the
office of personal management the opm
and normally when a federal employee is
subject to discipline they go before a
board in front of the opm
here
if they are going to refuse the order
that might be considered insubordination
then that might create a good cause for
them to be disciplined or terminated by
that board but now let's talk about the
much more controversial osha rule osha
which is a division of the department of
labor monitors work conditions for
private sector employees president biden
told the agency to draft a rule
requiring all employers with at least
100 employees to make sure their
workforce is fully vaccinated or require
unvaccinated workers to get a negative
test at least once a week osha's mandate
is to regulate the safety and health of
american workers and under the guidance
given to osha large businesses must
provide paid time off for their
employees to receive the free
vaccinations and for any necessary
post-vaccine recuperation companies that
fail to comply could face fines of
fourteen thousand dollars per violation
so let's talk about the legality of this
particular law or in particular this
executive order when people talk about
the constitutionality of a law this
generally refers to two very different
things the first is whether the
constitution prohibits that action so
say for example you wanted to wear a
t-shirt that says the draft to a
courthouse but a police officer arrests
you under a statute that prohibits
maliciously and willfully disturbing the
peace and quiet of any neighborhood or
person by offensive conduct well you
might have heard of the first amendment
and it turns out that the first
amendment prevents punishment for that
kind of speech those are actually the
exact facts of cohen versus california
and the constitution prevented that law
from punishing speech but the second
question is whether the constitution
allows and grants that power to the
federal government the u.s is a system
of dual sovereignty both the states and
the federal government are sovereign and
the constitution only imparts limited
powers to the federal government
generally the state's police powers are
much more expansive than the federal
governments though over time the supreme
court has generally looked to clauses
such as the commerce clause to find that
congress has pretty extensive powers
itself so let's answer both of those
questions about this particular vaccine
mandate so does the constitution
prohibit making vaccines mandatory and
the answer is no the constitution
doesn't actually prohibit such vaccine
mandates and the landmark case on this
is called jacobson versus massachusetts
during a smallpox outbreak in cambridge
massachusetts in 1902 the state of
massachusetts introduced an ordinance
requiring all adults to be vaccinated or
re-vaccinated against smallpox the
penalty for non-compliance was a five
dollar fine a man named jacobson refused
the vaccine saying it violated his
liberty now states generally have the
right to regulate the health safety
welfare and morals of its citizens these
are known as police powers however these
powers have been balanced with
individual liberty interests and the
question before the supreme court was
whether the 14th amendment's due process
clause allowed a person the liberty of
refusing vaccination the constitution
protects individual liberty but liberty
is not quote an absolute right in each
person to be in all times and in all
circumstances wholly free from restraint
quote the rights of the individual may
at times under the pressure of great
dangers be subjected to such restraint
to be enforced by reasonable regulations
as the safety of the general public may
demand so the constitution gives you
freedom but not the freedom to do
whatever you want whatever you want no
matter what and the key factor in the
jacobson case was the danger of the
smallpox outbreak quote the state
legislature proceeded upon the theory
which recognized vaccination as at least
an effective if not the best known way
in which to meet and suppress the evils
of a smallpox epidemic jacobson was
decided in 1905 when infectious diseases
were the leading cause of death at the
time the federal government didn't
regulate medicine or food and the public
health officials didn't have many tools
to prevent the spread of disease a
smallpox vaccine was a potent weapon
against a deadly outbreak so the court
didn't believe that the state had
overstepped its bounds to require
vaccination to stop smallpox though the
supreme court's jacobson decision didn't
necessarily give the government the
right to compel vaccinations in all
circumstances quote we are not inclined
to hold that the statute establishes an
absolute right that an adult must be
vaccinated if it be apparent or can be
shown with reasonable certainty that he
is not at the time a fit subject of
vaccination or that vaccination by
reason of his then condition would
seriously impair his health or probably
cause his death but generally speaking
according to the supreme court's
jurisprudence the constitution doesn't
prohibit states or the federal
government from mandating vaccines but
let's answer the second question does
the federal government and president
biden specifically have the power to
compel vaccinations through osha the
president's authority over osha is
different than his authority over
executive branch public employees and
contractors congress has the power to
make laws and that means that congress
alone can regulate workplace safety but
this is a very big job so in 1970
congress delegated much of its
law-making function to a federal agency
this is actually pretty common the idea
is that the executive is able to act
more quickly than congress and of course
congress can always take the delegated
power back this is pretty common and
we've actually seen similar things
before for example when president trump
used emergency powers to levy tariffs on
a number of u.s imports those powers
were delegated to the present in the
international emergency economic powers
actor aipa and i believe some of those
tariffs are actually still in effect
years later and with respect to osha
president richard nixon and a bipartisan
congress enacted the occupational safety
and health act which authorizes the
secretary of labor to create and enforce
workplace safety standards and it also
contains a general duty clause which
requires employers to provide workplaces
that are free of potentially harmful
hazards with the act congress delegated
most of its power to regulate the
workplace to the federal executive
agency osha osha enforces its standards
and general duty clause through
inspections citations and penalties now
osha's general mandate is to make sure
that employers prevent any kind of
recognized harm likely to cause serious
physical injury to workers in the
workplace and under that mandate you
could imagine that osha took the
position that kovid is likely to cause
serious physical harm to employees and
even without president biden doing
anything they could be launching actions
against firms that refuse to vaccinate
under the idea that they're causing
potentially dangerous workplaces that's
in the absence of any executive orders
employers can seek review of osha
enforcement actions first with the
occupational safety and health review
commission and then with the u.s courts
of appeal so taking the first part first
can congress really delegate its
legislative authority to the executive
branch well the answer is yes supreme
court ruled in jw hampton jr in co
versus the united states that yes such
broad delegations are permissible under
the constitution as long as congress
gives the agencies a quote intelligible
principle on which to base their
regulations the delegation will not be
considered unconstitutional however this
idea is not without its own controversy
at the turn of the century prior to that
case the non-delegation doctrine was a
principle in administrative law that
congress cannot delegate its legislative
powers to other entities so for example
in the ala shechter poultry case which
is a case you spend a lot of time on in
law school the supreme court held that
congress is not permitted to abdicate or
to transfer to others the essential
legislative functions with which it is
thus vested the supreme court has
essentially backed away from this line
of thinking though and a related issue
known by anyone who has ever sued an
agency of the federal government is
known as the chevron doctrine or the
chevron defense now that defense also
known as chevron deference is an
administrative law principle that
compels federal courts to defer to a
federal agency's interpretation of an
ambiguous or unclear statute that
congress has delegated to the agency to
administer the principle derives its
name from the 1984 supreme court case
chevron versus the natural resources
defense council now some republicans
have been highly critical of chevron
deference and donald trump stated
repeatedly that he would appoint judges
who would overturn the doctrine giving
federal agencies less regulatory power
and the supreme court's conservative
majority has expressed a desire to
reinvigorate the schecter poultry
analysis and curtail the federal
administrative state it's conceivable
that they might use that sort of
analysis against the biden vaccine order
and potentially unwind a lot of osha as
a blow to the regulatory state but as of
right now we can't say for certain what
the outcome would be but that's pure
speculation under current supreme court
jurisprudence osha is clearly
constitutional and this order likely is
as well the commerce clause gives an
agency operating under delegated
congressional authority the power to
issue a mandate that would be legally
sound as long as it's structured as a
requirement on entities in interstate
commerce or something that would affect
interstate commerce that's probably why
this order is directed only businesses
of 100 people or more businesses of that
size clearly implicate interstate
transport and commerce and
parenthetically that's often why you see
a lot of old federal laws regarding
crossing state lines and so the law is
constitutional and the federal
government has authority and there's
already precedent giving osha the power
to issue emergency temporary regulations
osha was created to protect workers from
entry and illness and these particular
orders are aimed at stopping the spread
of a disease that has killed millions
worldwide and osha will now have to
engage in the public rule-making process
which is governed by the administrative
procedure act or apa and here's a
flowchart showing how complicated that
process can be and if you're thinking
that this could take a really really
long time you're absolutely correct it
usually takes ocean average of 10 years
to develop and promulgate a health or
safety standard there are exceptions
however the one being used here is that
under certain limited conditions osha is
authorized to set emergency temporary
standards that take effect immediately
and are in effect until superseded by a
permanent standard these aren't governed
by the apa so when does that apply well
when osha determines quote that workers
are in grave danger due to exposure to
toxic substances or agents determined to
be toxic or physically harmful or to new
hazards that an emergency standard is
needed to protect them and it seems like
protecting workers from covet 19 meets
that standard however osha's power is
not unlimited for example osha is
precluded from duplicating worker safety
efforts in areas already regulated by
other agencies and the act also allows
states to control occupational safety
and health regulations through state
plans emergency temporary standards or
ets only last for six months and they
allow the executive to bypass the normal
commenting period required for
rulemaking under the apa now you can
imagine that once osha publishes these
emergency temporary standards an
employer who took issue with these ets
might argue that they're not necessary
to prevent a grave danger in the
workplace which is the standard you need
to pass an ets the argument would be
that most employees are already
vaccinated and if you're vaccinated the
chance of a breakthrough infection are
incredibly rare and then number two if
we're just dealing with the unvaccinated
there are other ways of mitigating the
risk they can wear ppe they can socially
distance and so
because those other measures are in
place they don't need this vaccine
mandate there's already things
done to to mitigate the effects of the
coppin 19 pandemic so you can imagine
that the biden administration is going
to make their cases persuasively as
possible when they pass these emergency
temporary standards and one has to think
that
a global pandemic is probably a pretty
good excuse to prevent this grave danger
from permeating throughout the entire
american workforce so how will osha
proceed here well the agency will
publish the emergency temporary standard
in the federal register it is then
subject to the usual procedure for
adopting a permanent standard except
that a final ruling should be made
within six months the validity of an
emergency temporary standard may be
challenged in an appropriate u.s court
of appeals this will of course be
challenged in those courts and it won't
be a walk in the park courts have
applied more scrutiny to osha's
emergency decrees than its regularly
promulgated rules of the nine times osha
used its emergency powers three went
unchallenged but of the six that went to
court only one instance was fully upheld
all the others were either stayed or
vacated by the courts so let's talk
about some of the potential problems of
this osha rule some argue that what
president biden has done violates the
federal labor relations act arguing that
these are the kind of things that are
subject to collective bargaining between
the federal government and federal
employee unions however it's often the
case that matters of public safety are
not things that are subject to a
collective bargaining agreement and that
may be the case here right on queue the
republican national committee has
announced that it will sue the dubai
administration to protect the liberty
interests of americans who don't want to
be vaccinated this lawsuit might
challenge several things whether osha
has the power to implement this rule
whether the mandate could be found to be
discriminatory or whether it denied due
process to people who were already
immune now some of those arguments seem
to be precluded by the jacobson case but
as to whether osha is the proper federal
entity to enforce such a mandate well
osha's been around for over 50 years and
it's withstood constitutional scrutiny
during that time it's possible the court
might change its mind but that would
take a complete reworking of the the
supreme court's current jurisprudence
and it would really alter the nature of
power in the federal government and as
many have pointed out this osha
regulation isn't actually a vaccine
mandate if a private sector worker has a
disability and can't take the vaccine
they can take a coveted test and may be
able to opt out of the test as well and
given the severity of the pandemic if
ever there were a time for workplace
protecting emergency powers you would
think it would be during a global
pandemic now whether they are legal or
not the biden vaccine mandates are going
to make a lot of employees get
vaccinated which means we're all going
back to the office sooner which means
it's time to start stocking up on coffee
again luckily i get all of my coffee
from today's sponsor trade coffee
trade's great because not only do they
have a huge selection of your favorite
coffees but they also have an awesome
quiz to get you matched with coffee
recommendations based on your taste
preferences i have very specific tastes
in coffee basically i want something
that tastes like hot chocolate and pairs
well with milk and sugar and trade was
able to find me the perfect roast and
now since the weather is getting cooler
it's time to ditch those cold brews and
go back to your full-bodied roasts for
pour over and with trade you can
discover new coffees from the nation's
top roasters trade matches you with your
own personal selection of coffee and
conveniently delivers it straight to you
choose your coffee rate it and your
coffee suggestions get even better it's
really the best coffee website out there
and if you already know what you like
then they probably have your favorite
roaster in stock at a great price you
can even choose whole beans or your
preferred grind so if you'd like to try
trade coffee legal eagles will get their
first bag free when they sign up all you
have to do is click on the link in the
description or the one that's on screen
right now and not only will you get your
first bag free you'll also get free
shipping so to get your first bag free
just click on the link on screen or use
the promo code legal30 at checkout plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel and while you're at it
click on this link with all my other
real law reviews so click on this
playlist or i'll see you in court